when's my turn that's 100 when's my turn
does she have to wait till the ex is
does she have to wait till the ex is I
DM out should I get the bull rolling try
my
[Music]
lot right guys as you already know we
just go straight into the nitty-gritty
Yeah question of the week you guys here
ready for the funny Funnies and the
question of the week was make me laugh
Daddy go what's the biggest lie that
you're still
telling oh did you think of that
yourself uh no I know you didn't cuz
that's unique it was a rhetorical I know
you didn't and the fact that you even
thought about it was offensive go on you
thought about lying to me tell your tell
your answers I wasn't thinking about
lying I was thinking about whether cuz I
obviously I always I put up questions
blah blah blah so they can give give me
some questions I was trying to figure
out where in the list it was and he was
towards the bottom so I didn't think of
it all right okay fair I was doing that
d fair fair trying to lie to my fans
friends my it looked like you thought
let me see if I can get away with it in
case someone's in the comments say
you're a liar I did it right the lie
that you're still telling yeah wow okay
what's the biggest lie that you're still
telling it's your baby I know that was
one in there oh there was loads of those
I didn't put I didn't put any of those
in I bet cuz there was flooded there's
going to be 400 of those women are
devils that I'm thick not
fat oh wow that's self awareness
starting off with like little ones and
then we're going to roll it through he's
going to leave his wife oh okay cool
that my boyfriend and I met in college
we met online and I'm just too scared to
tell my
parents
okay he would change he will change cuz
I stayed with him throughout his whole
time in
prison so he's going to be a better man
yeah n you're a mug you're easy useless
mug yeah across the forehead this
one go on that I don't
like I just activate porno mode and grip
my
teeth the lie that she's still telling
is that she doesn't like
[Laughter]
swear swear I just wait I'm not
done let me just the lie that she's
telling herself is that she doesn't love
I don't love I just activate por mode to
grip my teeth when an actual fact loves
it yeah it's a freefor
all that's too freaky naughty it is it
really is I love that it really really
is I couldn't I couldn't be told by the
one I share a bed with yes the one I sh
the one I share a bed with that like she
actually just loves it she's just been
lying cuz this a daily and you're going
to be walking right anymore fact it's
going to be so Danger
to lie you have to keep telling you
can't give me that level of Freedom
facts facts facts facts I'm going to
want it all the time yeah 100 p is off I
was about to say other holes are going
to get
missed they're just going to get missed
formes off the menu now I want something
else it's tighter it's
rper oh God oh God go go go go go what's
the biggest lie you're still telling
yeah my son's father passed away from Co
he's still alive he's just a dead beat
dread so Peak
damn that everything is going to be fine
it's been 25
years 25 years oh it's not going to be
fine oh that's hilarious bro 25 years is
Peak okay cool cool this is this is us
to a te that I'm going to start eating
clean I got something for that l
I'm glad you said that pinning it I've
got something for your later pause wow
something for that later carry on PA
yeah that my body count is three it's
actually seven the other four are all my
friends
ex's she's a bounty hunter wow time
anology a bounty hunter the other four
all my friend ex is that's you have to
say it's three that's naughty you have
to say naughty also I couldn't be the
boyfriend of one of her current friends
and hear the gossip she like you'll
never believe Sarah she's literally like
she thinks I don't know she [__] all
of the exes are think s and I'm I'm just
here like so why are we together then so
why are we together bang when's my turn
100 where's does she have to wait till
the ex is does she have to wait till the
ex is D out
should I get the ball rolling try my
luck I just put hashtag number five bro
Oh my days I made him cry during my
abion it wasn't even
his wow okay that's that's intense that
is intense couldn't face it it wasn't
even his damn that I love my boyfriend
that man looks like a broken egg and
he's broke
too so what are we doing then that I
love my boyfriend I don't know I feel
like like surely you would just
regardless of the situation you would
just leave bro you're just going to you
just have to leave why are you going to
put yourself through all of that bro I
promise you there's certain people I was
going to say women it's not even just
women certain people will just hate
loneliness more than being with someone
they hate yeah that's some they hate
yeah yeah they hate loneliness more damn
it's it's treacherous damn so you're
just you just end up in a shitty
situation yeah bro I'll just grind
through this shitty thing because it's
better than being
alone pointless anyway I've been 36 for
the last four years oh God that my
father is the biggest gunman in the
streets of Kingston Jamaica the truth is
is he's a police officer in Jamaica in
Jamaica oh that's the worst that's the
worst job have to tell Donnie I'm a gun
have to tell has to that I miscarried
his b B that [__] boy won't continue
through
me she just yeah she 86 the whole 86 the
whole thing the whole thing I just said
it was a a mishap a
mishap she 86 the whole thing charged
the whole the whole fertilization that
[__] boy won't continue through
me wow Jesus wow my man doesn't know I
found out he's married his wife and I
are plotting against
him I've said this before yeah that that
level of yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah you're
both wasting all your time precious time
and effort yeah because like if I get
confronted by one of you I'm going to
beg and plead if I get confronted by the
other I'm going to beg and plead both
you Charing it charge Char because I'm
caught and there's no there's no
feasible way out I've said this before
there's always a weaker one I said this
before there will be a weaker one and
one of them will want the to the Tom the
dick again yeah of course you just need
to figure out who it is yeah pick a lane
and stick to it yeah one of them will be
weaker than the other you just yeah when
they both hit you up on that FaceTime
You' be like not going to lie I expected
this of you and just look at pick the
weaker one point of the stronger I
actually expected this from you but you
you we ra ra chin you sweet one you're
surpris you surprised me that you're a
dark horse I wasn't I wasn't expecting
that from you I underestimated you I
underestimated i w do that
again the J I won't do that
again sold yeah yeah yeah facts facts I
know I've got s to sleep on I know I've
got s to sleep on and I'm moving back in
the bed yeah she's going to text you
privately come back come back come
you're such an idiot that's what she say
no swear words you're such an idiot
iroll come back
your bed's waiting for you downstairs
gang no funny business you can say
tonight no funny business I'm coming
back hard as a rock I'm walking in that
dance hard as a
rock oh God oh
God oh
Jesus God right I'm going to read the
last few back to back cuz these ones are
the most treacherous what's the biggest
lie you're still telling I tell my
boyfriend he's the biggest and best I've
ever had he's actually in the bottom
three see that's stuff that shouldn't no
no no no he's actually in the bottom
three cuz I've been told stuff we've all
been told stuff we've all been told
stuff it's now making me think what real
and yeah yeah yes I need the truth
because it's conviction I'm hearing
bottom three brother bottom three isn't
the the fact that she's lumping Mii and
two other brothers as well is is so
disrespectful it's vile it's so and I
don't even know if I'm the bottom second
bot some she can't be bothered to even
figure it out you're somewhere in that
somewhere in the bronze area and it's
just not working out it's not livid I
still purposely shake my legs so he
thinks I'm coming okay next again it's
not a lie but my husband continues to
tell the doctors he he's 6 foot that man
is
5'1 same you dog your six same no I
wouldn't dare I wouldn't dare I wouldn't
doubt wouldn't doubt I I always you know
how much of a pessimist I am I aim low
I'll tell them I'm 59 and they like shut
up are you and I'm like maybe 10 maybe
11 maybe 10 11 they're like 11 at least
say l all right if you insist
Jesus that I lost my virginity to my
friend's cousin when in actuality I lost
it to a prostitute
virginity virginity to a proy that's a
lot that would do stuff to me you have
to navigate that yeah really don't know
that's like um what's that film Benjamin
Button you ever seen life whatever it's
called Benjamin Button yeah I have there
the what it's called like the backwards
[__] of Benjamin Button bro something
something random like that the backwards
[__] of Benjamin Button bro he heard
like it bro he uh Curious Case yeah
curious case
I've seen it um yeah he he lost his his
viginity to a proie I can't remember
I've seen it once he was gassed off of
it as well I
swear off old and he worked his way back
yeah he worked his way he ran it back um
yeah bro I I wasn't I wasn't sure I
remember watching that film thinking I'm
not sure about this it was like his
stepdad or something or his uncle or
something that that put him on as well I
swear I yeah I was thinking I'm not sure
about this that's that's weird stuff bro
but he he kept running it back oh did he
fam once he'd been there the first time
every time he got a spare fight he was
in there clapping cheeks and as like a
16-year-old if I had access to funds and
lost it to a pro as well I'd be in there
oh yeah facts because that's all you
know that's the first and that's all you
know you you're just going to continue
CU it's easy communication fact
transaction there's no communication
need I'm getting all I deserve and all I
need bro it's not a good way to start
off your sexual ende it really then
you're going to start start treating
girlfriends like smack oh yeah
everything post a prostitute is a low
yeah oh bro because you've done stuff
why you chatting you've done stuff yeah
yeah you've done crazy stuff why are you
chatting
fast why you chatting I'm here for
business yeah yeah yeah bro what's all
this warm-up stuff oh God what's all
this Fourplay stuff
turnover last oh last couple rather I
lost my job because I was made redundant
due to the comp due to company financing
problems the truth the job was boring I
kept falling asleep at my desk and I was
fired after being caught twice
that's almost happened to me with Deo oh
yeah you said you slept in there I I
slept on the toilet after lunch almost
every lunch bro that job was so Bor oh
you know I I was only there for the bag
the bag seemed so healthy at the time I
remember when you told me was it like 24
26 something like that 26 that's a lot
at the time I've never seen money like
that yeah straight out you that's a lot
I remember told me I was like yeah I was
G I was jealous that I was so gassed and
then when I got it I was thinking this
is just not for me bro yeah yeah there
was no they just threw you in a deep end
there was no instructions nothing no
nothing bro it that's giv like
suits it was it literally was that
environment they would give me projects
and they' make me figure out who I need
to speak to for help and blah blah blah
like just tell me who I need to go to
bro I'm not I'm not doing this whole
learn on the job type stuff tell me
where to go what to do I hated it bro
yeah that sounds like an absolute
nightmare it was a nightmare G
rightfully so they to me yeah rightfully
so bro I was wasting their money 100
money and their time all right the LIE
yeah I lost my dream job because um an
old lady fell out of a wheelchair the
truth a random piss test came back
positive for
weed oh frustrating Jesus frustrating
indeed damn that was the U that was the
IG question the week that was juicy
thanks for that I really enjoyed that
that's one of my favorites in like the
last five or six episodes say so thank
you for that I wasn't expecting it so
guys welcome back it's a healthy juicy
Monday it is um thank you for the love
and everything that we got for having
darkest man on last week that was a fun
episode he did very well um and the
episode's doing very well we appreciate
you guys
um and yeah guys if you want to catch
more please head on over to patreon.com
shits and gigs please donate contribute
whatever you want to call it a measly
pathetic unnoticeable 3 pound a month a
day run the P to S and G and Indo
yourself indoctrinate yourself into the
cult baby culture where there your
daddy's just sitting on Thrones we're
just doing stuff saying stuff commanding
stuff and just like getting sucked and
laughing it's the dream guys it's the
dream and then you guys are just like
enjoying that with us exactly in the Log
Cabin uh and it's a sensational time um
in the next few weeks guys we've got
some big big big big big news coming
over
news kind ofing over on patre in the
next few weeks so stay posted on that um
guys if you are joining us on our second
leg of the Log Cabin tour Bristol
Manchester Birmingham on obviously the
tickets are sold out but if you want to
shs with us if you're coming to show you
want to party with us afterwards links
in the description grab your Afterparty
tickets right now and um come hold a
wine and uh guys if you're watching on
YouTube Please Subscribe standard
standard procedure subscribe um I'm not
going to ask you to like or comment or
anything just subscribe to the channel
do what it do um if you're listening to
the audio please do us a favor and leave
us a nice review We sincerely sincerely
appreciate it um I'm going to float this
idea in public right now
um might put um I know a lot of people
complain about the audio episodes um
obviously your boys need to get backs
we're transparent about it guys if you
listen on Spotify we get
bags and we we claim those bags and we
want to be rich so you're going to have
to listen to an ad or two facts you
might have to that's how it goes
sometimes there's a few more ads than
we'd like sometimes there a few more ads
than you'd like but you're going to
you're going to hold an ad or two facts
I think moving forward what we'll do is
if you don't want to listen to the ads
which is fair we'll put the full version
ad fore on patreon does that sound fair
that does sound fair we'll put the full
version adree on patreon if you guys
don't want to fun with the ads that does
sound fair I think that's fair that
sounds fair um but yeah anyway
guys I've got two things I want to chat
about okay I'm ready I'm
listening first thing when I said I got
s for your ass yeah um when I said I got
s for that ass bro you might not going
to be proud of me okay you might not
going to be proud of me okay so you man
or know all the [__] time m M when I
uh chat about like dieting and like gym
and all this kind of stuff
MH I always have this one like little
claim to fame thing where I'm like oh
back when I was dieting for a show all I
need to do is cut out Dairy gluten and
sugar and within 3 4 weeks your boy was
shredded and I was looking juicy MH have
I ever done it though since you been to
know me I've ever done it I just say it
I just keep saying it and it get fatter
and fatter and fatter I just and eat
that's all I do so this week without
even announcing it to none of you man
I'm about 4 days deep now I've cut out
gluten dairy and sugar I haven't touched
the stuff this week okay I haven't
touched it your boy's been eating
protein rice protein shakes um bare Udo
oil and [__] bare vitamins water and
they opened up a new David Lloyd that's
20 minutes from my house okay signed up
to that [__] Okay g sign up to that
that [__] not going to lie put it on
the business if you see in the
statements just stepping yeah keep
stepping keep stepping It's
deductible if you see on statements mind
your business It's
deductible
um he and that [__] is expensive anyway
your boy's been in the SAA oh God yeah
your boy's been in the SAA so I've been
training like a mad man like a mad man
bro my training for the last like last
week and this week I've been training
like crazy you man cardio heavy heavy
heavy weights um insane Doms and just
diet's been perfect gang you'll be so
proud and I'm not going to lie to you
man under this fabric seeing stuff G
we're only like four five days e I'm
starting to see stuff I feel like that's
when it kicks in a lot more like the
first week is when it's going you see a
a drastic change levels out obviously
we're on tour next week so I've already
mapped it in my head how you're going to
pass um and then me and um so basically
me and Louis are doing like
accountability stuff okay so we want to
make sure that when we train together
cuz we train together David Lloyd but
obious I'm not going there every day I'm
working it all around so whenever I'm
doing PT or wherever I'm training first
thing in the morning I'm not going there
I I have to message him on that day what
I'm training that day okay that he will
do the same so that the next time we
meet we know we can train the same thing
at the same time okay so he's never
doing back when I'm doing chest and then
when we get there okay he can't train
back I can't train chest all this kind
of [__] so makes sense accountability is
that every single day I'm messenger
saying I'm training this today I'm
training that today training this today
so in order for me to keep doing that I
actually have to train all the time and
train on the days that I say I'm
training um so already next week because
I know we're on tour next week um well
when this comes out this week I've
already texted him now saying I'm
training this on Sunday I'm trading this
on Monday I'm training this on Tuesday
and I'm training this on Wednesday um so
I know by the time we make it to brist
or Manchester my training for the week
is done I'm doing Sunday to Wednesday
done it's 30 nothing stopping me um your
boys on it bro your boys on it love that
and to transition from that this son of
a [__] started at 75 hard so chat to us
bro how's it going yeah bro it's going
good it's going good uh the thing what's
killing me the most is the water yeah
not the exercises I was like 4 and A2
liters or whatever yeah so it's two and
a quar of these oh that's a lot actually
this is two yeah um I'm bloated man I'm
going to the toilet all the time it's
crazy but that's that's been the hardest
bit of it actually the excis been okay
I've just been going for like 45 minute
walks and then either going to the gym
or been like working out at home so it's
been good I've been looking it uh I've
been liking it um I want to mix things
up a little bit because I don't want
every day to be too repetitive so I'm
thinking of like there's a rock climbing
place near mine I might and that's about
45 minutes so I might walk there there's
my 45 minutes and do rock climbing for
like an hour yeah yeah and then come out
fresh sick and then you get walk back as
well yeah exactly I can mix things up a
little bit so um it's been going good
though the reading's good I've been
reading um which has been a lot more
healthier like I've been getting my
reading in like mostly before bed okay
so like it just chills you out a bit
more 10 pages um what are you reading
currently uh I'm reading a book uh
called it's called keep going it's by a
um graphic designer who I like it's like
a graphic design sort of book it's
really really good I really enjoyed it
doing the damn thing yeah it's good man
I'm actually really enjoying sick I'm
not going to lie I placed a personal bet
myself I don't think we making it past
day 13 day 13 for him yeah I don't think
he's making it past 13 I've heard the a
lot of the um times where people fail is
two weeks yeah obviously your mate did
didn't he he was two weeks I think I
can't remember how many how many days he
did but I've heard I think I've heard a
few stuff online it's usually about two
weeks and people crack oh I bet people
just crack I bet bro yeah cuz it's like
the video I sent yesterday when it was
raining luckily I got off okay cuz as I
was just about to go for my walk the
rain stopped so I was lucky but um I've
still got to um I've still got to do my
exercises today okay I am going to do
them okay okay okay um yeah so I'm going
to um walk back home later later and um
do my exercises when I get in okay
decent fair play well played dude I'm
very proud of you bro that's insane and
like you were a big impetus as to what
like put me in gear cuz I
wanted I wanted to start this thing the
gluten-free
thing long story short I had loads of
people around my house I was making a
shepherd's
pie and I wanted to make a separate
shepherd's pie yeah
um for me that was clean yeah and
everyone can have the creamy cheesy
dirty one mhm I made it I use a whole
bag of potatoes when I say because I
have so many people around my house yeah
there wasn't enough potatoes for the two
Shepherd's pies so I had to charge it
pour my potatoes into their potatoes mix
it and eat the the shitty one and it put
me so depressed that I went to Crispy
Cream box of 12 and I was like I'm
smashing these to the point where I
actually feel sick and I don't want
sugar anymore so I can kick this [__]
in tomorrow jeez as listen to me as I
was on donut number fix your face as I
was on donut number seven you seven is
always your benchmark yeah as I was on
donut number seven halfway through my
phone vibrates this son of a [__] day 1
out of 75 and I was like wow wow look at
me look at
me I had glisten sugar like everywhere
down me and I was like this guy's just
started a 75 hard and I'm ballsed deep
in these donuts oh God so the next day
every day since then I've been yeah I've
been on it I've been on it eating wise
and I've done very very very well okay
very well very very well my my eating
that's sorry I forgot to put that up uh
yeah my eating's been clean I've cut out
like um I've literally not having crisp
not having uh chocolate sweets like
everything's cut out man like nice bro
I'm literally just eating clean I've
like not getting any takeaways said to
myself like everything I have has to be
like homemade nice um well play yeah
yeah everything like I'm not having um
yeah like even like my snacks and stuff
I want to start um making like some oat
bars as like snacks and stuff like yeah
Jesus we'll re up next we'll re up next
Monday keep see where you're at um next
week I'm just yeah
bro I'm very proud of you bro that's
that's that's decent um that's very very
motivating as well um not going to lie
like I said day 13 I reckon you're going
to crack but okay I will be impressed
okay I'm glad it's motivation and what I
will be impressed of if you do crack and
then start again yeah I I'll will rate
you more than anyone I've ever R in my
life because I promise you I'm not
starting it again facts I've done two
weeks i' I've tried it I've tested it
I'm done yeah yeah I'm over it what's
your energy levels like sound sound uh
I've not noticed a different yet
difference yet because obviously I'm on
day four now yeah I'm on day four now so
I've not noticed anything mad okay um
but it has definitely been good uh the
walks have been amazing for like stress
and stuff and just like day to day
having a walk every single day and just
literally getting outside is amazing
like really really good obviously like I
said the reading is brilliant as well so
um yeah man it's that's amazing bro for
you very good toar um right next up I
have a question for you me personally
you personally okay random right okay
okay wait let me take a sip so scenario
cool let's just say for some reason
we've let's say we've done a brand deal
with Flippin da cathlon right okay and
they want some content okay so we had to
go up into like a snowy mountain in in
Wales or something M it's freezing MH we
shoot the content for the day mhm and
then we have to Camp mhm so we're
camping we obviously got two separate
tents yeah it's chapping we've been both
been trying to sleep for like an hour
and a half you're going to ask me if I'm
going to broke Back Mountain
wait so we've been trying to sleep for
an hour and a half it's freezing it's
like 1 in the morning and we're over
it we're over it yeah as you're tossing
and turning cold cold cold cold cold
can't find the warmth all you hear
is my eyes would first open you hear
first open yeah and in the in the
doorway it's just me yeah sleeping bag
up to here and your boy's doing puppy
dog eyes God and say Daddy I'm freezing
please let me get you Daddy I'm freezing
are you letting your boy in or
no I mean we don't have to share the we
can just we're just sharing the tent
right we're sharing the tent it's tight
it's fam it's
snug yeah but and obviously I'm I'm I'm
coming in for body heat oh so yeah so
even if there's space your boy the
sleeping bag is irrelevant you coming in
with your sleeping bag is irrelevant cuz
you want my sleeping bag no no no I'm
willing I'm willing to sa my seing bag
but don't get it twisted I came for heat
so you want to wrap up yeah I want I
want s touch me touch me I came in for
contact so what's the question so are
you letting me in to snuggle or you just
going to firm it and freeze
tonight I would let you in because I
can't see you I can't see that see that
face of yours and be like bro bro I'm
[__] freezing please but I don't
think i' let you snuggle me no you'll
say go away no no no you'll be in the
tent you'll be in the tent but when I
say snuggle I don't need to hug you or
anything like that like I'm I'm in my
bag but I need to feel something like I
need heat I've come in heat like there
can't be a gap between us if if I'm in
my bag you won't be able to feel the
heat oh yeah but you can because the
Heat's transcending through like you're
radiating your bag I'm radiating my bag
and like an AA thing is just we're just
Clos yeah the then is just yeah on a
back Tob back T yeah on a back to back
on a back to back you let me in yeah
okay calm gang gang gang what's your
Tipping Point though so on a back to
back thing we're calm but then like you
say say say this is your back this is my
back mhm and then and then you just feel
you just you just feel that you see the
B you feel the base of my spine pushing
against the base of
yours because you're trying to you're
trying to get C yeah yeah I'm snug like
that and then all you feel is
like yeah just just
Arch you feel the separation of the
midback and the the lower the lower
region the coxic just pushing I'm
shifting forward you like this yeah so
that's what I'm saying what's your
Tipping Point I mean are you just going
to firm it firm my snuggles and firm my
arches I'm not going to firm your arches
because I'm as your arching I'm shifting
yeah but the Wall's here there's only so
much tent fair you're shifting on
following I told you I came for heat
yeah I'd rais my
voice I'd wake us all up I'd raise my
voice I'd raise my voice be so angry at
you and be angry at the cathon at the
same time cuz why you why have you put
me
here I raised my voice fair fair that
will put me in my place that'll put me
in my place like why have you put me
here why are you in this
position all right yeah say l say l say
l say l say l that's funny made you
think of that I don't know just came to
my head that's all I wanted to know bro
hilarious guys we're taking a super dup
super Looper quick break to pay some
bills and the way we're going to do that
is VR
manscaped manscaped have brought out the
Platinum package 4.0 oh this is the one
stop shop for the man who deserves it
all like me and FES facts they designed
this package specifically to allow you
to fully align your entire hygiene
routine with Elite products inside the
Platinum pack package you'll find the
lawn mower 4.0 trimmer one the weed
whacker ear and nose hair trimmer two
Ultra Premium body wash three Ultra
Premium 2in1 shampoo
plus conditioner four Ultra Premium
deodorant five crop preserver
anti-chafing bll deodorant six crop rev
revor bull spray toner seven
anti-chafing boxes eight and the shed
travel bag to hold all your goods while
traveling that's nine things my guys
nine things if you want to get involved
all you need to do is head over to
manscape.com and punch in the exclusive
code which is SN SI November Golf and
that's going to give you a cheeky
naughty 20% off and free shipping let's
get back to the episode thank you very
much top five uh yes it's time for the
fun game top five let's go everyone grab
your boards grab your markers I think
this one is going to be very cool I
think I'm going to get an array of
answers
okay but all of you are going to try
very very hard to win this O Okay
because it's an it's a very eclectic one
that may have differences of opinions
mhm which I like so the top five of this
week is the most popular sitcoms on IMDb
most popular sitcoms sitcoms on of all
time of all time on
IMDb
ooh
interesting okay thanks for that anytime
feel free to tell
me like feel free to like refuse to
answer um
do uh animated shows count or no do they
count as sitcoms or they cartoons no
they count as sitcoms oh [__] oh boy
really that's thrown off my entire anime
counts as sitcoms not anime wait what
did you say anim animated not anime oh
sorry I thought you said anime no oh
[__] animated does count of sitcoms M oh
God
H that's thrown me way off I'm glad I
asked but I wish I didn't just going to
warn you man now if I've asked that
question and there's not a single
animated show in the top 10 I'm going to
kick up a
fuss okay just warning you guys
now okay I'm going to blow up cool so we
all locked yeah yeah yeah all right bet
um REM can I have yours first please
okay so I've Got
Friends Family Guy
Simpsons
Simpsons I love that that moment where
someone says knows Simpsons good sh get
Ellis I don't want to speak you're so
dramatic yes
simp uh and then I was struggling future
armor and my stab in the dark is Malcolm
in the Middle oh love that show I hated
it you hated Malcolm in the middle bro
thought he dead nah bro Brian Cranson is
a genius in that show he made that show
um I don't remember it that much um I
know I used to watch it but I didn't
really pay attention to it great show um
Ellis pass huh pass I'm joking um right
the thing is I heard you say pass but I
wasn't sure not not on big big
YouTube
um um right oh Jesus right Only Fools
and Horses
sh I'm talking about old school
friends Big Bang FY this is where I
tanked Little Britain Little Britain
yeah and then [__] sake and then and
then I did fre you did what three points
a ler in a packet wow three points bro
BBC 3 days I used to bang that two in
the morning wow three PS you know it was
always on where nowhere watched yeah
yeah yeah yeah Jee
Jesus wow forgot about
family you talking about um what's his
name um Seth McFarland like he's come up
in conversation in the uh in the studio
quite a few times as well uh right I've
done friends yeah Seinfeld yeah the US
Office South Park and big
bang South Park South so I wasn't sure
what class is do you know what our class
is a sitc sitcom a laughter track oh
what sorry a laughter track yeah
audience that's why I asked about the
animation otherwise otherwise I would
have done just those like us office I
wouldn't think that's a sick I thought
it was a mockumentary if if I didn't ask
yeah I was going to put uh I had I'm
interested to see where it is I'm not
doing honorable mentions but I I rubbed
out to put South Park in I rubbed out
all a sudden in Philadelphia so I'll be
intrigued see if that's in the top 10 um
okay guys just to recap everyone's
answers remu friends family guy Simpsons
future Malcolm in the Middle Simpsons in
sh Ellis you went Only Fools and Horses
friends Big Band Theory Little Britain
three pants of loger
James L
manry I'm laugh do you know I'm laughing
because if you had said it with such
confidence it wouldn't I would have just
charged it was you giggled
before knew it was uh James friends
Seinfeld the US Office South Park and
Big Bang
Theory right South par top 10 oh God I'm
nervous about this one number 10
Brooklyn 99 oh damn okay I didn't even
rate Brooklyn 99 like that what Brooklyn
9 he's good iate top 10 of all time yeah
I wouldn't have said it was top 10 but I
think it's funny I do think it's funny
um so yeah number 10 is Brooklyn 99
number nine Simpsons who put Simpsons
ram ram fair play well done uh cross
that out cool number eight Rick and
Morty damn number seven which I think is
[__]
controversial Ugly Betty wow dead ugly
baay bro ugly baay yeah number six close
but no cigar
Seinfeld cool and now we're hitting top
five top five
number five Modern Family I love modern
I
love one of my favorite I'm annoyed
about that goodness I love Modern Family
number
four and only two of you got this Big
Bang
Theory Ellis and Jimmy number three only
one of you got this and I thought fair
play cuz I think this was a Rogue one as
well future Rama really let's go that is
Rogue yeah when you said I was thinking
I kept it to myself I was thinking
damn damn future Rama that got canceled
after like four seasons that's hella
random I'll go with that fair play
number
two everyone got this friends Okay cool
so it's two's up so so far Jimmy's got
two rem's got two Ellis has got two yeah
but J got Sith in with s
Seinfeld yes so let me just recap what
you guys have before we get to the
number one so what you've got left Ellis
is Only Fools and Horses Little Britain
and three pites of lger REM you come
clutch with this imagine I will never
play top again what you've got left is
Family Guy and Malcolm in the Middle
Jimmy what you've got left is South Park
and the US
office yes it's got to be and the number
one show on
IMDb category sitcom is drum roll
please none of the above I'm joking it's
the office oh yes
bro [__]
sake sced me well played well played
well played well played South Park for
reference South Park is number 14 Family
Guy is number 13 so that you were you
guys were very close and that Malcolm in
the Middle is probably won't be though
I'm still scrolling I'm still scrolling
still scrolling that was my long shot
how's future armor better than South
Park I don't know future Armor's great
though I'm not going to lie I don't know
bro but yeah is um is always sunny on
there or no not in the top 50 really
that's surprising they're were like
season 10 yeah I know I know which is
weird but this is this is what it is
this what it says but well played guys
you did well so REM if you're ready can
we have the trash news of the week
please boy let's go Japanese husband has
gone 20 years without speaking to his
wife since she upset him Jesus reason is
not there as to why she did so or she's
not speaking to him question is one what
do you think she
did two are there any dilemas or ass or
am I the [__] which would pertain to
that which would pertain to that would
make sense as to why uh a husband can go
that long without speak speaking to his
wife and
three what would make you personally not
speak to your wife for for that long I I
can think of two scenarios we've had
yeah in which would would would would uh
yeah would bring me to Val yeah yeah
yeah first what do we think she did um
yeah what do you think she did for him
upet him what what um I don't want to
get the I don't know if that it says
what where are they from Japan did they
say Japan literally says Japanese is the
first I wasn't even reading that I was
looking I was looking at them I was
looking at them I didn't even see the
Japanese okay be because I'm trying to
figure out obviously Heritage and like
their we let's just let's address the
elephant she didn't do much did she
let's just address the elephant in the
room Japanese she didn't do much I feel
like she um she went against his like
ways of life a little bit she affected
his his honor and and his pride is M his
pride is Mur 20 years
um she put too much like rice wine in
the sushi and it's he charged the whole
marriage oh the eel wasn't fresh that
like that oh to much gotu Jang yeah yeah
his body was hot and he's
FS she didn't take her shoes off before
she walked into the yard take her shoes
off before the yard fact fact he said
you think it's a zoo you think it's a
zoo oh what my parents going to think
what my friend's going to think yeah his
mom was there and she just watching
shoes on on yeah and the mom said Rong
the disrespect yeah yeah yeah he said
say less you think I'm a mark I'm I'm
just Tak with shoes yeah okay good Shout
with shoes shoes yeah um I don't know
what she could have possibly done not
going to lie they look like they've been
married for a minute so I'm going to say
yeah something that we
wouldn't something we wouldn't condone
in the Western World minor minor minor
but the two things I had in my head was
like if it was my wife and for some
reason I'm staying with her fact that's
the thing I was thinking for some reason
I'm staying with her but I would be
willing to go 20 years without speaking
first would be the one we read last week
about um home girl asking can she bang
the ex again if my girl if my wife had a
terminal illness and she was like I'm
not going to lie to you please my dying
wish is I need to [__] my ex again and
then for whatever reason she just made
it yeah they gave her like 9 months to
live she just made it yeah I'm not
speaking to you again until you actually
die yeah um second one into my head was
going through the phone and seeing um
the message from next Donnie saying I
can't I I thought you said you had a gag
reflex I thought you said you had a gag
reflex I promise you now if I saw that
on my wife's phone I would go 20 years
without speaking to her
I 30 40 50 as many years it takes
because I'm putting myself in the shoes
of this Japanese Donnie and I'm just
going to assume
is frowned upon to get a divorce hence
the reason why he's sucking up his pride
to stay with her but not speak that's
too dishonorable to get the divorce you
know I mean that's why I'm putting
myself in his shoes your failure as a
man I can't receive that text as fuad
you know what I mean I can't because the
scenario would be different very
different no one's I'm not speaking to
like this 20 years thing is long um so
yeah it has it has fam it has to be a
situation like that a text message thing
and the thing is like
I just I just can't
see I feel like she disrespected them in
a way that probably has something to do
with another guy but she wasn't the
instigator I feel like because she
condoned it or whatever just allowed it
she just allowed it to happen he was
done he was done with her yeah yeah yeah
we can't leave her can't leave her bro
what would the streets yeah yeah facts
it's his Sur him at the end of the day
yeah fact bro it's not it's not we
household exactly it can't run in public
you can hold my hand or whatever we can
do all these things but I'm not talking
to youing to you at yard best believe
I'm swiping that ring off you yeah fact
and we're just going our separate ways
bro gag reflex that's the only words I
was saying in those 20 years yeah yeah
when when I'm when I'm at my gag reflex
yeah
swear n and then I'll just go back to
being silent yeah cuz you need to
outline her and then just sit down and
start being silent again yeah yeah like
every other year or something oh bro
every other year gag reflex are you sure
bro 20 years is a crazy that is crazy
that's that's stubborn what does what
does some of the comment say R um she
has to admit she's wrong then he'll
speak um I looked up he was jealous
because she was giving all her attention
to their three kids which is what a
parent is supposed to do sorry that's
childish behavior damn okay m
um whilst he thinks he's got her to her
it's a blessing in
disguise mad yeah she's not she's
clearly not pressuring him for nothing
yeah she's not asking no questions in
that house like she she's quite content
with this lifestyle clearly that's crazy
even though my man sleeps with his back
to her every single night maybe she's
all right with that I couldn't last a
month with that I couldn't it's
exhausting it's exhausting I could I
don't think I could do a week I don't
think I could do two days if if we live
in the same house I don't think I'd make
it two days not speaking no no no no my
aniy with through the roof I also need
love yeah I need physical touch and I
need love so bro we can't be in the same
yard just silence like that no I jump
bro yeah yeah yeah facts one of us have
to jum yeah yeah this is not working
yeah there's no love language there J
it's nothing so yeah whatever you
need you come says wait you can just do
that facts a lie bro that can't be
that's that's obviously not normal hence
being trash news like that's crazy bro
damn bro fair enough all right man fair
play well I wonder when he cracks if he
cracks if he cracks after this long I'm
not cracking even if I'm over it I'm
just going to make it it's been 20 years
I'm charging it he's probably got a new
thing on the side
yeah yeah he's talking to someone
someone yeah all right gang um okay cool
you've got um a dilemma for us M hi guys
love your p and thank you for getting me
through the toughest days with pure joy
you give me okay my dilemma is I am
finally with the love of my life in
Brackets met in high school didn't date
but had sex a few times I always knew I
wanted him forever fast forward several
years we meet back up in life I am now
40 he's 43 she wrote in capital letters
I'm in the I'm in my [__] sexual
prime I she 40 she's 40 in a sexual
prime all right I want sex every day and
hope for it twice today my guy May once
SL need sex twice a week and he but he
genuinely loves me sometimes he just
wants to go for lunch and talk with me
just hold hands and enjoy each other's
company I want to [__] and suck often
this is the only thing we argue
about our relationship is perfect
otherwise and we have no trust issues I
have never cheated and never will he's
all I want he's all I need and holy [__]
he's great in bed he doesn't he doesn't
enjoy when I'm sexually aggressive and
prefers to let him come to me which
again is only once or twice a week if
I'm
lucky would I be wrong if I occasionally
slipped his sexual slipped him a sexual
stimulant to satisfy my sexual urges
nothing too serious just to make him
want to [__] me your advice PS I won't I
won't make any moves until I see the
response on the show I value your
opinion
by the way for a little more context
this is a serious relationship we are
moving in together in two weeks after um
after having been dating for one year
and he's mentioned marriage we do
everything together even doctor's
appointments first of all too much
information um
facts recap or no I got it I got it say
less she wants to slip him drugs to bang
her yeah stop what you're doing stop
stop this gone way too far
yeah um this has gone way too far but
he's not he's not going to know though
obviously so that doesn't matter bro I'm
I'm just scenarios I'm just doing
scenarios in my head all all right all
right yeah he's not going to know I'll
let you answer but like and what when he
has a heart attack then what yeah finish
your T all right say l
right I'm just going to say it how I
would feel it is cuz what am I 32 my
knees hurt m my ankles hurt when I'm 43
yeah two times a week I'm assuming I'm
going to be calm with it yeah my
testosterone's dropping this is a matter
this is a fact of life bro and like
don't get me wrong I love you but your
fault let's let's drink it in bro let's
just say it how it is so so I'm saying I
love you yeah but you're 4 I want you to
be my wife I'm 43 but testosterone's
taking a nose dive and babe you're
40 my girlfriend's 40 yes you want to
[__] which is banging which is banging
and I'm gas and like I said let me
reiterate I love you we're going to get
married yeah but you're 40
okay
now I'm just saying stuff right yeah I
don't even know what this she looks like
so this is not personal to her but she
is 40
is Kylie Jenner 40 nah okay I'm saying
yeah yeah yeah if Kylie Jenner wanted to
Su me off five times a week I'd probably
have it I'm just saying but if my wife's
40 yeah I might need a buffer a 3-day
buffer to really let the balls grow then
I'm going to run you
over but I'm I'm 43 yeah I've I've seen
stuff in my life yeah 40 yeah you might
be
horny but father time gets all of us
this is me and you he gets both of us so
I'm glad you're horny and I love it
don't first of all don't sliit me
nothing yeah cuz I promise you we're not
moving in
anywhere if I find out yeah if I'm just
getting random and
also Ed if she knows what amb she want
to give man yeah I Al say I don't think
she understands how horniness works yeah
she does because I'm not going to get a
random boner and think wow I must want
to [__] my wife I'll be like what's
going on what's going on cuz I'm just
eating porridge bro I'm my di [__]
solid but it's not you're thinking these
Quakers are turning me on bro but it's
not it's solid but it's not
tingling tingling this is force fet on
yeah it's not natural chemist chemical
reaction this is blood yeah it's not
tingling for something it's not sniffing
for nothing bro it's just hard um so
first of don't sleeping nothing yeah and
second of
all maybe get like a little 25-year-old
Su on the side if you're that horny just
don't let me know about it okay but as a
43y old man I'm not banging you twice a
day and that's just how it's going to be
that's my personal opinion okay that's
just how it unless I'm going to get on
some testosterone replacement therapy
they'll beit a trt to all my juices this
is what it is bro Fair um okay what if
for
example somehow she slept she slipped to
your little something let's say an hour
before she planned to have sex with you
or whatever um but you didn't obviously
you didn't know what you're drinking
whatever you just backed it in whatever
juice she gave you um and for some
reason obviously at that point you're
about to have sex or she started to lip
you so you slowly start to get aroused
now tingling yeah yeah but the sex you
have is like well I've not felt this in
a minute let's say you've not felt this
in a couple months you
[__] we just bang we just and you you
know when you nut and then you both roll
over and you simultaneously breathe like
de both catch your breath but you're
both catching breath and thinking wow
wow wow what a session like you want a
high five what a session you think I
need to run that back next week or not
next week
tomorrow would you think would you would
you
mentally want to run it back or would
you think
this was just a one-off because it could
have just been like a place no I I I Pro
it will the highlights alone will make
me horny for the next three or 4 days
the highlights I learn from that session
I'll be like wow yeah this is buff and
I'll be I'll be just remembering her
like face down ass up I'll be thinking
Jesus I need that today and then that
will keep me going for like 3 4 days and
then we're going to go we're going to go
back into Old Cycles fair I'm an old man
bro Fair yeah don't I was I was just
given like a little side scenario but
anyway I I agree like don't slip
personal don't slip me anything I'm I'm
I'm 43 if you slip me something I might
slip on the floor I'm I'm old now yeah
um that's long I feel like what you need
to do obviously sexual your sexual
energy is a lot higher than his um and
like you said James 43 I've seen stuff
I've seen all seen stuff like I'm well
seasoned so it's like there are certain
things that just
won't get me on it every day to day to
day you telling me that your horn is
just not going to do it for me day to
day to day today basis like don't get me
wrong I love that your sex drive is high
and that's gang for me cuz now I know
whenever I want it it's there bang it's
dead you know what I mean so don't
change and don't take that away from me
please
but maybe just just invest in some sex
toys just just get some sex toys and be
open and say babe I'm horny as [__] if
I'm going to be up just be like babe I'm
going to be upstairs yeah that's all I
need to know it might tingle me all I
need to know doing what I'm going to be
upstairs and you're doing what find out
if you find out if you want to find out
or I'm going to be upstairs just
carrying doing what you're doing I'm be
like [__] and all of a sudden you just
hit oh I'm sprinting upstairs this is
what I'm saying but like I saying today
I'm spring up next week I might not but
then the week after that I might again
so that's good that's a good shout um SE
man when we're in our 40s we're going to
need to find out ways to get there
otherwise because like I yeah like you
said bro I've seen stuff I've had all
the sex there is to have so this whole
like I'm in my sexual
prime cool that's good for her but I
don't I don't know how you're ear your
priming your 40s yeah I don't know what
happened you must been suppressed but um
I mean props do you yeah um but yeah I'm
I'm imagining myself as a a 43 year old
man come on man that's a decade away
banging you on a Monday and then you
won't see me till Thursday Friday yeah
yeah week I work for a living facts I
work for a living facts bro I'm tired
bro um but anyway that's an interesting
Dilma yeah for the love of God don't
sleep him anything yeah please don't
yeah them toys and if he's a real one
he'll come up and there even if he's not
going to bang you he'll come up and then
finish you off like he like he'll finger
you he might go down you he'll just use
the toys in you like he'll get involved
even if he is not in the mood to bang
you he will participate he'll exactly he
participate for you cuz it's it's your
bag at the end of the day too like so
yeah yeah man that's juicy sex toting
all right fair play right I have a
thread to finish off okay I hit me okay
cool so this is [__] this is the
picture yeah oh yeah yeah yeah fat
hickey on Donny's neck yeah and the
title's Fellas give me your best excuse
if your side chick leaves this on your
neck oh God yeah
bro so hickey on the neck yeah how you
explaining yourself one BR said I was
swimming and an octopus got hold of me
Fam in deep oce deep I was I was deep
diving and octopus got me he got me bro
Fair yeah just one yeah yeah yeah yeah
just caught me with one thing
right this one is Gaslight bro it's a
birthmark I've had it forever you really
don't pay attention to me do you do you
even care about me oh that's G
like I I wouldn't be able to get through
that sentence I'll start sweating and
shaking fact she'd probably slap me fact
you s what are you talking about if
you're going to lie like properly shut
the [__] up I can smell spit on it I can
smell the spit on it shut
up oh one guy just said seat belts been
tripping SE bel's been tripping bro yeah
yeah a F this was sweed me hit me my my
uncle likes to goof around when he's in
town what B my uncle likes to goof
around when he's in town Town what
that's that's open up so many questions
bad questions I can't say that to her
yeah yeah yeah what does that mean what
does that actually mean was he fighting
you was he sucking your neck oh my God
what's going on Whose uncle is this fact
bro one bre said I was attacked by a
vampire oh God
twilighting doc says it's neck cancer
but I'll have it beat in a
week I'm think he
SW in a week say less don't even worry I
have it be in a week be fine next yeah
you got to see it you got to see it
fading yeah yeah yeah right last
one I got I got I
got I got bit by a snake and the homies
tried to suck the
poison
oh oh my God I couldn't have your grown
lips sucking I mean I need them there
but I couldn't have your grown lips
sucking my I promise you I'm not doing
it bro you already know from the
Hollywood thing I'm not doing it okay
that was my [__] and are you not sucking
my
neck
PA bro all right cut the thread are you
not sucking my neck no bro why am I
sucking your neck a not again with this
bro there someone there to do it no
there's not going to be anyone
there it's not going to happen we're in
the Welsh Ms again
like okay let's just run it back please
pay attention this time all right give
me the scenario last time I asked you if
a r snake bit me in my dick yeah would
you suck it off and fairly I mean not
fairly but you said you wouldn't suck
the poison out my [__] that's fair bro
that's fair okay fair enough I I battled
with it at the time I'm over it yeah but
my neck if you fit me in my neck you're
going to let me die so cuz you Sal pois
on my
neck I hold on because there are so
many right there's so many things I'm
thinking about yeah yeah yeah I'm either
thinking about what position am I
putting you in to suck the poison out of
your neck one yeah two if I do suck the
poison out of your neck I'm just
ingesting poison no you spit it out bro
but it's still in my it's still in my G
it work like that it doesn't work like
that you spit it out and it's done you
not seen the movies bro suck and spit
over it's a movie bro this is this is
what I have it's a movie just don't
swall to spit for 10 minutes rinse your
mouth out with what and if you swallow
it it's going to go it's going to go in
your stomach you'll burn it off it's
calm people people in like Mexico drink
shots with like poison in it oh yeah
they do to be fair you're
calm and I's worried about positions
whatever position you need me in bro
whatever position you need me to suck it
at please bro bend me up man said there
be someone else to do it you're my best
friend who who else is sucking it I'll
get a scalp and a slice you and then
what squeeze it yeah like force feed it
out all right do what you need to do
that I would do but what if you don't
have a scalpel I'll find something I'll
get a pen or
something always something with you I'll
get a pen neck there honestly always
something with you it's my neck
bro a lot that's a sensy spot it's my
neck the neck is s that's a spot cuz I
can get close to the ear by mistake you
know what I mean and before you know I'm
token
[__] because what what can never happen
I promise you now James I can't place my
lips on your neck and the peripheral of
my left eye sees you lick your lips yeah
fam lick lips and my eye grab the back
of your
head
[__] I can't hear a murmur out of you
bro you'd have to be dead P fam oh yeah
I'll try I'll try but I know cuz that's
my like you that's my S
ticklish cuz I know for about I'll be
like ah I'll grab it ah and then I know
you want to stop so when you try to I'll
grab I'll be punching it's in there I
promise you I'll be punching everything
I know what happened bro you'll place
your [__] thick lips on my neck and
I'll say ah and then I know you'll be
thinking [__] this and I'll grab your
neck I'll grab your neck suck it out bro
please I'm sorry suck it out oh my God
[__] please suck it
out oh oh God that's two jokes that's
too [__] we're going to end that
[__] here all right gang we're going to
charge it there thank you guys head know
visit patreon.com and see us on Thursday
love love
[Music]
love